so this is the position it's my
grandfather's board the one you all saw
the one I took to the signing in Zagreb
that some of the Grandmaster have signed
it is white the plane and win the game
not an easy one as black is threatening
Checkmate but I'm sure you guys can
figure it out uh yeah if you've paused
the video of course the movies Rook to
F1 with check absolutely spectacular and
now Comes The Rook captures on F1 and
now Queen to H2 with check absolutely
stunning King has to capture and now
Pawn captures an F1 and also brings the
Knight into the game this comes with a
beautiful a royal Fork the King has to
move doesn't really matter where and now
Knight captures a queen and that's it
you have a knight your opponent doesn't
you easily win the game that's pretty
much it hope you enjoyed it once again
happy International Chess Day